hi everyone welcome to android developer
lab plus for the 15th of november so
we've had a bit of a break last week but
went back this week and it's been mad
busy week android 4.2 is really today's
hangout actually is a is all based
around android 4.2 and what that means
to developers so I know Ankur Kotwal and
I'm joining from the Sydney office and
I'm joined by my colleague Tony hi
everyone so Tony is joining us from the
front office so well let's get started
with this week's our topic and it is
android 4.2 which is also jelly bean so
usually we start these presentations
with news but we have so much news that
the news became the topic for the
presentation itself all right so Android
4.2 was released a day before yesterday
for for those people that are in
Australia you know time differences it
could have been yesterday for you
depending on where you are so android
4.2 is known as jelly bean the google
managed nexus devices are starting to
get OTAs or over the air update so that
includes the google provided galaxy
nexus 'as as well as our current
generation of nexus devices the nexus
for the nexus 7 and a nexus 10 and for
those of you that were lucky enough to
get through with the pre-orders you get
to try it out on your Nexus 4's and
Nexus tens very soon so that's really
great and I'm sure there's a lot of
people looking forward to that one thing
I wanted to point out however is that we
have this site where you can download
nexus factory images so a lot of people
actually use this as a way to shortcut
the process and update sooner but the
reason I wanted to point it out is
really for our developer community
because one thing that I found very
useful to do is occasionally if I want
to go in
sure or test my apps on all the releases
of Android like let's say gingerbread or
even ice cream sandwich and you can go
to this site and download those factory
images and roll back your developer
devices so that's a good way to have you
know a single physical device but test
across multiple versions of the android
platform so yeah keep it in mind as part
of your developers toolbox alright so
enter a four point into it is called
jelly bean internally we've the version
code that we have is actually called
jelly bean mr one and it is API level 17
now the reason i mentioning that that
that we have a static defined for for
jelly bean mr one is because you may
have some code in your apps that you
want to version gate now typically we
don't you know it's not necessarily good
practice to version get your code but
there are times when you need to write
so if it's if your version gating
against this version its android OS stop
build version codes jelly bean mr one so
one of the things that many developers
we've encouraged in the past on a do
plus to do is to update your app so that
you're targeting the latest version of
the sdk and if you go back to our first
ad 0 plus we talked about the
androidmanifest.xml file and really we
we dived quite deep into that but one of
the things we covered was how you update
your app so that you're targeting the
latest SDK and that is sdk version 17 so
in your users sdk flag in your Android
manifest file you would just change that
to 17 now there are obviously good
reasons to do this often we enable
things and newer versions of the sdk
that are unavailable in older versions
so for example if you're running an old
app and it doesn't it's not version 11
or upwards then you won't get the holo
theme on devices that support hollow so
it's always a good idea and in general
is good practice
to always target your SDK to the latest
version you should use the minimum SDK
version or min SDK version attribute to
specify how far back you want to support
and of course there's a whole bunch of
development tools like lint that will
help protect you from invoking code that
isn't supported on this those minimum
SDK versions so you should go ahead and
do that for for for jellybean mr1 but
there are some caveats so in API 17 if
you target API 17 there are some
behavioral changes that we've introduced
to the platform so for example content
providers now when you declare them the
default value for the Android export
attribute is actually false so keep that
in mind when you update to these to
these latest versions of SDKs we make we
occasionally make changes like this and
this is actually quite well-documented
on developer.android.com but here's a
summary anyway the other thing we've
done now is when you request the
permission access course location and
you don't specify access fine location
the accuracy that you get back off that
location will always be around the city
block so in the past even if you didn't
request find locations there were times
when your accuracy could have been
higher you're the accuracy now will
always be course if you haven't asked
for fine location and it's really just
making sure that we're consistent with
the permission you're requesting the
other sort of God cheers or changes that
you should look out for other some
settings in the settings dot system
class that either I read only or have
been moved to settings global now
there's some good reasons for us doing
this an example of that is airplane mode
the traveling of an airplane mode and
android 4.2 now has multi user
capabilities so you can have multiple
users on your Nexus 7 on your Nexus 10
and so if you share the your tablet with
your
with a family member or a friend you
know that they basically have their own
set of applications and they're in their
own and those apps have their own sort
of data so you know some of these
settings are now going to affect users
across the the system itself so they
have moved now with those settings
whether you target API 17 or not on
devices that are API 17 and higher those
settings will have moved so we kind of
know are basically if you are accessing
those settings and trying to change them
we you want your app won't just start
crashing but it'll basically have no
effect if you've tried to write to one
of these older settings and so keep that
in mind as Drive Android 4.2 some of
these settings have changed and you
really should follow up in the
documentation as to which ones so we've
introduced something new that we called
a dream and daydream is is really need
for for users because it's like an
interactive screen saver that
automatically kicks in when the user has
put their device on a dock or it's the
devices are idling on a charger and the
reason that it's really nice is that
it's another way for you to engage with
your users it's another bit of
interactivity that you can add for your
app that drives users to your content so
we've obviously got your typical
activities that users interact with
their we we've had widgets that allow
you to again have some dynamic content
on users home screens we've had
notifications that allow you to sort of
remind users that hey something
important has happened and again it's a
way to engage or you've used it for
things like music control so that users
can interact with your app without
having to dive into your app daydream is
another alternative with an interactive
screen saver mode so the the picture
that we have there in the top right hand
corner it's that the gallery screens
have all the picture screensaver and so
those pictures there although they keep
coming up on this particular day dream
you as a user can actually move them
around so touching the screen doesn't
boot you out of that daydream so to
implement a
you have to look at the dream service
API and in a lot of ways utilizing this
is similar to building activities for
your apps so you'd call setcontentview
after you've attached to a window and
then there's a there's a set of
overrides that tell you basically the
state of the dream so on dreaming
started on dreaming stopped you can also
do other things like call set
interactive to say that has yes you have
an interactive dream it could also be a
passive dream where it's just as soon as
the user interacts with it sort of gets
you out of the screen saver mode and
then you can also toggle things like set
screen bright so some of these daydreams
the clock one is quite a quite a neat
one because it it's sort of it acts like
an alarm clock it shows you the time but
the screen is actually quite dim and
dull so that you know if the users that
have it on their bedside tables you're
not illuminating the whole room just
with a daydream so you have some control
over that once you've actually started
you built your daydream you need to
remember to declare it in your manifest
so you'd have a service and you make
sure that you'd added the intent filter
for it as well so those are daydreams
this one I'm really excited about
because it has a lot of potential and
it's basically that we've added a set of
second screen AP is so the nexus 4
utilizes miracast wireless technology so
that you can actually have an app
running on your device but displaying on
it on a second screen like a TV or other
devices that support the the miracast
standard now the interesting thing about
this is you're not just limited to
mirroring what is on your device as a
developer you can write use basically
the presentation class and specify user
interfaces on that second screen that
aren't the same as what you have on your
your mobile device so you can have this
this distinction between the passive
experience and an interactive one so if
you're thinking in terms of games you
might have on
your device you might have the the heads
up display let's say it's a racing game
you might have the heads up display or
the controls visible on the screen but
on the second screen you may want to
ditch those because then you can just
watch how the race is going and you may
not even show the same perspective where
you might have the driver mode
perspective or first-person mode on your
your mobile device on a secondary
display it could be a more cinematic
mode that's that sort of has the camera
outside of the vehicle so anyways to use
this this API you can use either display
manager or media router classes to
detect whether the device has connected
to a secondary display whether there's
one available and then you would extend
the presentation class and then you
construct your your class your extended
class with these display objects now one
thing to keep in mind and this is really
important is that more often than not
the secondary screen will actually be a
different resolution and a different
size to what your mobile devices so you
shouldn't make any assumptions that your
layouts need to be the same even though
they will you know if you're doing the
mirroring type mode then yeah sure but
if you're building custom displays for
the second screen you need to use the
resources that are attributed to that
presentation class so within your
presentation class you call get context
and call get resources so that when you
load resources to display so let's say
drawables for example that it's getting
them from the right right folders
whether it be xhdpi or hdpi or even
using you know the DP smallest width
qualifiers so you need to keep that in
mind when you're working with this that
you have a different set of you can have
a different different set of resources
on the secondary display compared to the
primary one so really awesome stuff
there I'm I can't wait to see what comes
out of this I'm sure this is just the
start of something really big for a
second screen apps the next one is
actually one of my favorite new features
which are lock screen widgets
and basically what it means is that
typically what we've had so far on the
default launcher I know they've been
some third-party lock screen apps that
could do this but on the default
launcher you could you'd have the time
and then you have your you either you
know have the slide to unlock type thing
with the circle to go to camera or
unlock or even Google now or you'd have
the entry for your your password or
pattern and so on well now you can
actually have other widgets than just
the clock there and this is not just
with the I mean this is in the default
launcher but we've added the ability for
you to create your own widgets by
default if the devices will come with
you know things like calendar jamel also
another clock widget which is actually
you can see what your international
clocks but we can't wait to see what
users will how they'll expand this
capability so basically all you need to
do is have a typical app widget that
you've always had and you'll you have to
add a new attribute again in the
manifest where you specify that the
category of this particular widget is
also on the home screen so this is a new
attribute this widget category attribute
and if you don't have the attribute that
the default value is home screen but the
new value and I mix this up before but
the new value is keyguard should say
that it shows up on your lock screen
tony was there something you were you
were saying yeah I was adding like gmail
we have a richer for Gmail as well ah
gmail yes of course yeah I'm not too
keen on sharing my gmail on my lock
screen but I'm pretty particular about
security but I can see how it'd
definitely be convenient so keep that in
mind as well by the way that when you
add these widgets you want to do it want
to add capabilities in those widgets
that are still respecting the privacy of
the the user from a security point of
view it is keep in mind that if somebody
you know steals a device that's locked
by a password that the people that have
got hold of the device
can't add screen they can't add widgets
to the lock screen without unlocking the
device first so we've tried to be
particular there but you know AB
developers you can put in you can show
whatever you want in the view so keep
that balance in mind now it's important
that you specify an initial layer and
you do it again with an attribute called
initial keyguard layer and and basically
disallowed this is the initial layout
that's shown and then you can lay out as
you go through for those are lock screen
widgets are we also added multi-user
support yay finally so that means now we
can do things like tablet sharing
between family members or friends as an
app developer you actually don't need to
do anything special to have your apps
work in multiuser mode there are
exceptions if you've been sort of
bending the rules and right you know
hard coding paths in your apps like / SD
card and making assumptions around you
know what directories to store data in
your potentially adding security holes
because you could be writing now data
for a for user one in a bin an area
that's globally visible even by user too
so we've always had a set of methods
that gave you access to specific story
directories if you weren't using them
before please update your apps to use
them now because it can be seen as a
potential security risk so on internal
storage you've got things like get files
do i get kk stir and open file output
but external storage and often this is
this is a really cool part of it is the
get external files there and get
external storage public directory so
yeah it's this is again I mean it's
totally seamless otherwise to developers
but that's on the assumption that you've
been doing the right thing so it's worth
auditing your code if you if you're
unsure what what you've done here
and of course with every platform
release we have lots and lots of other
editions so things that we've added
right to left support in views for text
rendering you in your application you
have to add an attribute called support
RTL and then you have to go and define
your views accordingly as well we will
also now added something that developers
have been asking for for a while which
is called nested fragments so you can
now have a fragment within a fragment to
nest them what you need to do is call
this get child fragment manager when you
fall for when you're doing your your
fragment transaction then you can see
there's some sample code there that that
shows you that when we go to do the
transaction the begin transaction is
actually called on get child fragment
manager and we are adding the video
fragment to an existing fragment rain
descriptors also has seen some
improvements things like script group's
script and drinks intrinsic and filter
script so you know grouping your debut
code in renderscript we we basically
have continued to improve the
performance and parallelism of render
script so you get some tremendous
performance out of it and we've added
some new capabilities there that will
make it easier for you of course now
that we have a new platform release we
also have some great updates to the
developer tools so now we have an
awesome improvement to the layout editor
that layout editor that we previewed at
Google i/o but basically as you can see
from the screenshots we have we have
this main view open which which looks
like a tablet layout and then we've got
a bunch of small thumbnails on the right
those thumbnails are actually showing
previews of that same layout on how it'd
be rendered on different sized screens
and we've obviously got some profiles
there for the nexus one that the nexus s
Galaxy Nexus Nexus 7 and just a 10 inch
WXGA tablet excuse me and as you make
changes on your main
editor there he will automatically
update the other layouts to show you in
real time what those changes look like
so you don't need to toggle between them
you can see all of them at once now this
is really handy for where you're
targeting multiple layouts and I hope by
now developers that you are targeting
multiple layouts because you know in
this day and age if you're not doing
tablet and phone layouts these are
opportunities that you're missing out on
of course we've added more lynch rules
link is probably my favorite feature in
the android sdk tools it finds all sorts
of potential runtime issues but it finds
them at compile time so it's really
really useful and we've added invited a
bunch of new rules there and we've also
continued to increase the number of
templates app templates that we have in
the sdk tools so you're not having to
write as much of that boilerplate code
as you've had to in the past we've added
a new UI automated test framework
basically we have a viewer that allows
you to scan and analyze your apps user
interface and then there's this UI
Automator java library that has a set of
AP is that allow you to create
functional tests finally we now have
something that they getting developers
have been asking for for pages which is
a one click sdk install package so you
can go and download this one package and
it comes with the includes development
development environment as well as adt
the android developer tools the sdk
tools as well as an emulator image and
the AP is for the latest version of
android which of course is 4.2 the
Android virtual device creation dialogue
has also been given a new lick of paint
it's a lot nicer to use now and yeah so
for those of you that have you know go
and create different combinations or
maybe these to try out different layouts
and so on this is a
nicer so you can see right off the bat
there that we can add that we've added
things like being able to specify
cameras they're turning on GPU
acceleration just with that used jeep
host GPU checkbox it's a it's a lot
nicer a lot easier so one of the things
that we've had the users come back to us
as what developers come back to us and
say hey I've got a 4.2 device but i
can't find developer options anymore in
my settings and what we're going to be
doing is we're adding we're publishing
an app on Google Play that enables those
those developer options but basically
you can you can get past it by going
into about tablet or about phone if you
if it's are you sure on the phone and
tapping the build number i think the
magic number of times you need to tap it
is seven but after you do it two or
three times it tells you things like you
are now four steps away three steps two
steps and so on and then it magically
appears this screenshot was put together
by someone on google+ moretz Hulk's Dorf
and i said thanks for that so that is
really just a real quick rundown on all
the new capabilities of the android 4.2
platform we're really excited because I
think there's some great new
capabilities here that developers can
really take advantage of to provide
unique and compelling user experiences
but before we go to Q&A we should talk
about something that we announced over a
month ago was called a TL plus
experiments when we talked about the
connectivity ap is and we'd asked a
bunch of developers to all of you
actually to build us something cool to
show us utilizing those api's and then
we were going to discuss it on a future
episode of a deal plus well
unfortunately we are going to call that
a failed experiment it didn't we didn't
get too much interest from developers so
we're looking at ways on how we can move
forward with that program we do think
that there's some really
bandages there but we we probably need a
different approach so on that night
let's move to Q&A it we've got a set of
moderator questions I'll just see who's
live we've got linden and marco life so
if you guys have questions feel free to
ask us now and we will after after that
we'll go to moderator so Linden has
pasted some questions in the chat does
the support lib provide the get child
fragment manager method so i don't know
if it's specifically that method Linden
but we've actually added support for
nested fragments in the support library
revision 11 I think you might need to
I'm not sure whether it's called exactly
the same thing it might have the word
support in there somewhere but I'll have
to just look it up for you yes Lisa yeah
let's go um I can talk about as well I
you to throw um yeah look I mean other
any quotes with that um any sort of
known other teens I suppose that you
guys have seen already armed or it's a
pretty straightforward and pretty robust
um it's it's pretty straightforward
pretty robust the only I wouldn't call
this a quark but the only got sure that
you need to be aware of and it's the
same one that's always been there is
that you don't want to be mixing support
fragments and native fragments right so
in your app if you're using fragments
you're either use support fragments
throughout will use negative fragments
throughout they are different classes so
they don't just you can't just
interchange them and expect them to work
also a Tony Sorry mate where you are
looking to add something to that oh no
no it's fine yeah okay
um alright Marco did you have any
questions for us um yeah I asked if
there was any I guess best practices for
using nested fragments I wanted to see
if there's any gotchas or anything that
we should be looking out for like I
noticed that when I i had a fragments in
a viewpager that were hosted by another
fragment I could no longer set retain
instance on the child fragments you
could know mr. okay i'm not i'm not
familiar with that actually because it's
such a new API I must admit I haven't
had a chance to play with the nested
fragments in the support library so I
don't actually know the answer of for
this one off the top of my head turning
oh so I meet me neither but I think we
we are planning wedges just talking
about this attitude we will have a
separate ADL A+ session that your
presentations focusing on nested
fragment so um so we will gather like
some of our teammates live feedback and
the best practice and we will represent
that in the either in a more formal our
session in the in the future so awesome
sounds good all right ah I'm sorry sorry
measure like a lot ya know just let's
take a look at some of the questions I
asked on the moderator maybe yeah i'll
just share the window okay okay so the
first one is Android 2.8 support ipsec
VPN using psk i think are especially is
a big pep and ms chap arm is not in four
point x anymore why is it removed or is
it possible to intimately paying client
support that um so are
I I don't think in terms of API I don't
think we have happened chap in through
API but so last i checked in the
improper know we we do we still have PS
k but but not like for pep and chat
configuration so we need to we need to
check with the team see whether we move
this suspect for secure reason or for
some other reason um so I guess next
week we can find find find find the
answer and get back to our from them so
okay is it possible to use view page
page transformer with Jake Wharton's
nine old androids library to make the
animations on page views backward
compatible to OS 2.1 so I seems Marco is
this the same is it you or a different
marker nuts me so I personally have not
used Jake's nine old androids library so
I'm I'm personally not sure about the
the compatibility there and I suspect
he'll probably know because the the
viewpager paid transform has been around
for a while right tony is there anything
you wanted to add to that are not with
the viewpager okay so we'll yeah we're
not sure marco i suspect try asking Jake
will try and follow up in a future
episode but we don't know right now okay
what is the feature of android 4.2 or 3x
is the best for making static pages not
five to seven I do not want animation
the static pages content text of eternal
truth okay that's interesting
I may change the font style but not the
text content so I think this person just
basically saying that they've got five
to seven pages of text they don't want
to animate from there so I'm guessing
maybe they've got like a next button and
it just refreshes the screen is that
your understanding of this question Tony
yeah so I mean there's lots of ways you
can do this if you're just using a
single text view you can you know just
listen to the button click for for
whatever next or if you've got a swipe
gesture and just update the the text in
your text views alternatively you can
change the views that you show so you
may have you may not want to reuse the
text view for whatever reason and you
may have a different set of text view so
you can just hide the existing ones show
these ones you could probably go from
activity to activity and say that you
explicitly don't want an activity
animation so look there's lots of ways
to do this the animations are kind of
there to give a more pleasant user
experience but if you're after something
that's quite no frills and you just want
to change values and lots of different
ways to do it all right this was Marcos
question around the best practices when
nesting fragments within fragments and
we're going to get back to that and
we'll talk about nested fragments in the
future in an upcoming episode okay
there's a link here to action quick
clock do you know yep so so that the
quick clock we are referring to here is
in info porn are in 4.2 if you drag the
notification tray down and its really
are right on top like is really like our
clock we're talking to so and and
understand the tax mentioned is not
triggering the intent but I just add
to try it myself with an intent and it's
actually launched on my application
properly so is with eat that clock when
you track down the notification tray is
we do the one up on top so that's the
one we were referring to default ok so
the ex I don't know if you're watching
but if you still can't get it to work
obviously tony has a solution so feel
free to just reach out to Tony
afterwards and maybe there's something
in your code or your solution that
doesn't match this ok when does an
Android start supporting the bluetooth
i'm at profile i think the great jelly
bean is missing it so we typically don't
talk about we're not able to talk about
features that you know went when we're
bringing features to to the platform so
the answer is really i we don't know but
it's it's something that we can take
back to our engineering team to say hey
developers are asking for it any
highlights on the Support Package
revision 11 so ah yes and let me just
share that particular window with you so
if you just do a google search for
Android support library this is the
first hit you'll get support package
revision 11 we've got a set of new
capabilities i already mentioned the
nested fragments there's there's some
some classes there for the viewpager and
some accessibility improvements as well
so here's the full list of them and yeah
you can go through them in detail for
you know the ones that are relevant to
your app ok let's go back to the
questions last one Tony another VPN yeah
so punched a link so since VPI a prvt
napi is available in four point oh and
this API help making connections or is
still
no it's not supported in this API also
arm so I look at the question so and
also the API is that the API itself is
actually helping for preparing are we
playing connections I I think I think it
actually does what from our was asking
so if not from ping me and we can we can
look into this further so I think that
open API does what you ask okay great so
well that's that's the full list of
questions for today and people that are
that are watching live if you have any
more questions please post them either
in the the thread or if you're live
Linden marker if you've if you've got
any other questions now's your chance
yeah I got something on working on
something at the moment that's a the old
sort of a credit card swipe you um now I
made something similar earlier this year
before i knew that gallery was
deprecated and so I was going to go grab
that code and then tweak it a bit and
then saw obviously galleries deprecated
so I'm looking at the i'm using the
viewpager within a view pager at the
moment because the the the outer work
out a sort of you is in a view pager so
you can swipe the whole pages across um
that's okay because you know I can I can
arm I can push on the emotion onto the
inner viewpager without a problem but
i'm also using that set child clipping
false trick to show the neighboring
items in that view pager um and that
mark know if he's got a post about it
this bunch of people that don't be to
work about it um but I'm finding it's
it's really nasty I mean because you end
up with a view pager that's really
not the full width of the screen and
when you go to the end when you sort of
motion for the end you're getting that
the glow pop-up not on the edge of the
screen but no halfway in there's also
some artifacts in there if you hold if
you hold your finger down and slowly do
emotions I just wondering do you know if
there's a better trick out there that no
one's been talking about so let me just
get a better understanding because this
this concept of putting a viewpager with
interview pager seems seems like it
could be quite confusing to users
because if you're using you know in the
outer view pager you're going you're
using swipes to swipe through the outer
view pager then you suddenly end up on a
specific page of that out of view pager
that's now consuming those swipes you've
kind of broken the swipe navigation yeah
I'm aware of that and I trialed it the
the really that I think that there it
actually tilts the Arkansas actually
getting by having you know the the main
navigation in a view pager and then you
hit a page and someone accidentally
swipes or swipes on this interview pager
they've just found out really obviously
but that is a its own little motion
element so in a way that that outer
swiping hints to swiping anyway and
there's plenty of other room to swipe to
get to the other pages there's tabs as
well so they can click on it my personal
preference would be that you wouldn't
want to override the horizontal stripes
of markers have it's a conflict of
swipes and I agree with that that you
probably wouldn't want to override that
swiping behavior from the outer view
pager to suddenly an eno on other things
you could consider is for that inner
view pager that you have now could that
could that instead of swiping
horizontally be a vertical swipe so
horizontally is taking you across
categories and vertically is the one
that you said
credit cards right so if you've got a
set of cards instead of having them next
to one another you have them you know
vertically sorted would that be
something that that might be useful
that'd sort of work until I go and chuck
it in a scrollview or something like
that so I'm I think I'm taking a nap
that's on iOS and it has that swype
mechanism but it's sort of going from
from a dashboard into each section and
I'm trying to sort of flattened the
whole navigation for android to make it
a lot quick it again into the app a lot
more straightforward and just sort of
cutting the crap so to speak which is a
long Australian last time um so yeah
it's it seems to be working i don't
think the problem that i'm seeing is
really to do with with a a mix-up of the
motion itself it's it's more i think
that the viewpager is is designed to
take up the full width of the page and
because of that you know that the stuff
that you could do with gallery in terms
of having you know multiple light and
seeing slide by sight and nestor the one
that it is currently selected it's just
not as I'm not really seeing a drop-in
replacement with view pager for that
kind of functionality yeah um I haven't
had to resort to that clip clipping a
trick that you've mentioned the one
thing I to ask is could you just try
this for me and I just don't know if
there's a conflict there could you try
having that in a view pager not be
nested inside another view pager and
just see if that those same artifacts
whether you're still seeing them and I
just don't know whether because because
you've got a view pager within a view
pager I don't know if there's issues
coming from that or you know the other
the fact that you're using this clipping
feature yeah yeah I'll give it a shot
breaking it down
and yeah might might even cut some code
up someone so if you get a chance of the
world trunk just seems sad like from
like a android usability point of view
like your users might not be expecting
that you know the the way that you're
using a viewpager within a view pager I
just I don't think I've seen it in other
apps on me yeah I was very cautious and
aware of that and so I trialed it and
and to be honest my finding is that
actually it hints more that that that
interview pager takes motion because
people are already doing rushed across
the screen um you know otherwise you
have a static page that you can't you're
not doing motion on and you need to have
some kind of hint like hey you can swipe
across this but if they're swiping
across things and then you know suddenly
an inner Swiper moves by itself my whole
page doesn't it's actually sort of Iraq
and honestly it's sort of working a bit
better that way but yeah we'll so we'll
see what happens that the artifacts what
I like so yeah actually if you could
also um if you're going to reach out to
me with some some code if you could just
take some screenshots or a small video
or something just to show the artifacts
or send an APK um you know if it's if
it's credit card related you might not
be able to send me in every case oh I
just know it's it's cards I'm just
saying the credit card thing because
that's the sort of typical widget that
people are saying you know Google Wallet
by kind of stuff has that kind of swipe
card thing yes oh and you know it's it's
a pretty common thing in my wildest
these days but just that the drop in the
gallery whatever reasons it's got its
own problems but but really it was it
was able to provide that functionality
better on yeah I'm the only other thing
I'll say and I don't want to dwell on it
too much but because you've got this
nesting within a alternatives to that is
that your top-level view pager could
instead be the spinner on the action bar
which obviously acts as a drop down or
the sliding drawer really works well
because you can you can see all of the
categories you now have supporting icons
as well so you can still have the the
swiping left to right for the the card
view but navigating across categories
could be done by a spinner or sliding
drawer okay yeah alright cool alright
thanks for that um I don't see any more
questions on the thread so yeah alright
well thanks for joining and hope it was
informative will catch you guys next
time thank you see you later see it